Christian vom youtubeekanal besser hat
mich zu einem Gokart Rennen
herausgefordert der Haken das Ding muss
selbstgebaut sein und damit unser
selbstgebautes Kart das selbstgebaute
cart von besser abzieht werden wir da
einfach den dicksten Elektromotor
reinbauen den wir finden können dieses
Video wird unterstützt von steuerbot
mehr dazu später folgendes wir wollen
catc bauen das elektrobetrieben ist die
Idee ist dass mus catc baut und ich dann
damit ein Rennen bestreiten mus das
heißt du bauchst einfach so dass du ir
danach Monat Urlaub hast oder was du
auch ja
im Krankenhaus und wir suchen jetzt hier
gerade auf Ebay klein auf nur noch klein
an zeigen eine gute Basis dafür J
perfekt da kW rein und GI oder ja wir
machen noch ein dicken Elektromotor ran
das ist Teil wirklich einfach Schub hat
also steht elektrische zusatzantriebe
mit Akku egal in welcher Form erlaubt ja
aber das heißt ja dass wir einfach da
den dicksten emotor Welt dran bauen
können sollte teilweise Muskelkraft
betrieben werden können wir machen
direkt emotor an die Hinterachse dran ja
über eine Kette halt
wahrscheinlich kannst nicht so Nitro
extreme Air das kostet 90 € hat ein K
frei nein wir lassen die Pedale einfach
mit 1000
mitrehenel deine Füße ja wer sagt dass
du deine Füße reinstecken
sollst Sitztiefe verstellbar Alter ne
Leerlauf
Leerlauf was geht Alter hallo Tom und
Sandra wir wollen gerne das getcard für
unseren Sohn
[Musik]
Manuel
wie
geil a so euren Sohn habt ihr dain
gelassen W so geil wenn wir einfach ihm
das nicht gesagt h und er holt ab und
sagt aus
Manuel oh
Gott wä eigentlich auch geil oder oder
Gangschaltung normal legang zum
anschieen Handbremse ja ich meine mit
Freilauf ist halt so vorteilhaft schon
bin voll gespannt was die vom SE
Auspacken ja
ja das rote wä glaub ich schon mein
Favorite fast das geilen ja ich glaube
schon das schaut großen Ganzen schon am
stabilsten
aus
[Musik]
ready die Katze reibt sich an der Linse
so
warte jetzt ja ja
okay
so Transporter haben der wird noch zu
einem Camper umgebaut aber jetzt als
erstes natürlich erstmal das umgebaut
und davor will ich mal testen ob ich da
überhaupt reinpass also es ist
eigentlich für Kinder gedacht aber also
es geht schon also eigentlich geht's
nicht ich hau mir meine Füße an das geht
überhaupt nicht aber ich glaube wenn man
Motor dran hat kann man die fü auch
einfach nach vorne machen okay
Vorwärtsgang ja aber Rückwärtsgang gar
nicht eigentlich schon ah doch
Rückwärtsgang einfach zurücktreten ja
okay h voll geil der lauft das ist
wichtig und wenn ein Gang angelegt ist
drehen sich automatisch die Pedale wenn
man hier fährt und wenn man schnell
fährt würden die einem wahrscheinlich
ein Fuß brechen ah Leerlauf und dann
Vollbremsung boah das bremst sogar
wirklich geil anders wie bei unserem
ferngesteuerten Auto ja das hat nicht so
richtig
gebremst dann schauen wir uns mal
an was wir da überhaupt so gekauft haben
hier an ah ja da fallen schon die ersten
Schrauben
raus sehr geil na ja dreh mal um schauen
wo die Schraube herkommt da sind
bestimmt noch ein paar
mehr
mhm diese Reifen ja davon ist einfach
nur ein angetrieben nee das geht so
nicht also was mega ist wir haben hier
dieser gangschalter das ist halt
wirklich einfach für Kinder ausgelegt
die ganze Hinterachse hier kommt mir ih
bisschen ganz schön instabil vor weiß
gar nicht was Pascal für ein Motor
bestellt hat
8 kW bei 8 kW da macht das Teil einmal
Spirelli ja wir bauen das auf jeden Fall
erstmal auseinander wir fangen mit den
Reifen an hier Reifen 1 ist ab ich meine
immerhin hält die Klammer ja nur einen
Reifen da würde ich auf jeden Fall drauf
vertrauen so umdrehen und oh Wunder wer
hätte gedacht dieselbe massive
Metallklammer die auch den Reifen da
drüben gehalten hat haben wir natürlich
hier auch dann zerlege ich das Ding
jetzt erst gar nicht mal weiter sondern
mach mir Gedanken ob wir nicht doch
einfach die Achse bisschen verstärken
und bisschen modifizieren dass wir das
ganze Ding so beibehalten können dann
bleibt hat unser Radstand auch relativ
gering was glaube ich ziemlich geil ist
so ein kurzer Radstand viel Power
relativ unkontrollierbar da sehe ich
doch Thomas drauf ich würde jetzt
erstmal anfangen und ma hier diesen
Metallstern der in die Felge greift hier
für die andere Seite noch wie wird das
eigentlich verhindert dass sich die
andere Seite dreht ah doch die
Kugellager hier na ja gut das ist kein
Problem da Schweißen wir einfach die
Kugellager fest und dann dreht sich die
andere Seite auch erstmal messe ich mir
den Metallstern der eh schon auf der
anderen Seite ist aus und konstruiere
mir den in CD dann kann ich mir nlich
einfach eine Schablone ausdrucken und
das Teil easy nachbauen die Schablone
schneide ich mir erstmal mit der Schere
aus wenn das jetzt aus Metall auch noch
so easy wä als Material habe ich mir
eine Platte aus einem Reststück Metall
ausgeschnitten und die Schablone mit
Sekundenkleber drauf geklebt wo später
die Antriebswelle reinkommt habe ich mir
ein Loch gebohrt erstmal klein vorbohren
und dann mit dem Stufenbohrer hinterher
dank der Schablone kann ich mir die
Sternform erstmal grob mit der Flex
ausschneiden und dann alles schön mit
der ile Nacharbeiten das schaut do schon
ganz gut aus und bevor wir den Stern
drauf Schweißen brauchen wir auch
erstmal noch die restlichen
Antriebsteile die auch noch auf die
Welle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
müssen so ich habe jetzt hier unseren
Motor geschnappt der dann später an das
Teil dran kommt der schaut schon so aus
als wir das ernst meinen wird später
hier sitzen kann sich schon sehen lassen
denke ich Schweißen wir das Ding mal
zusammen wir wollen ja dass die
Kettenspannung einstellbar ist deswegen
machen wir den Motor hier mit
Langlöchern fest die zeichne ich mir
jetzt erstmal an ich habe mich jetzt
erstmal dafür entschieden das mit der
Flex
aufzuschneiden weiß jetzt nicht ob es
besser oder schlechter funktioniert halt
als ich mir vorgestellt habe wir haben
auf jeden Fall zwei Langlöcher da
[Musik]
drin genau und hier werden festschweißen
und das ist der ganze Lack nicht
verbrennt bzw dass wir schön Schweißen
können ma ich jetzt erstmal den ganzen
Lack hier
[Musik]
weg wenn da später die Kette drüber
kommt kann man mit den Langlöchern hier
Kettenspannung
einstellen die Welle bzw die Ritzel die
wir haben sind im Innendurchmesser ganz
Ticken zu klein deswegen müssen wir
jetzt unsere Welle bisschen abschleifen
deswegen haben wir uns jetzt hier un
wilde Drehbank selber
gebaut
wie angegossen wunderbar den
gangwalhebel hier rein sind wir schon so
gut wie fertig mit
der so gut wie fertig mit der
[Musik]
Antriebsmechanik für unseren Akku den
wir später noch am Kart befestigen
müssen brauchen wir auch noch ein Halter
dafür habe ich mir den guten alten
flachstall geschnappt und mir den
erstmal der Bandsäge
zugeschnitten nach ein bisschen
Schweißarbeit war das Ding auch schon
fertig und kann un Kart den Halter habe
ich dann vorne im Auto befestigt mit den
6 kg die der Akku auf die Waage bringt
können wir den Schwerpunkt zumindest
noch ein bisschen optimieren weil Thomas
und der Elektromotor relativ weit hinten
sitzen kann das nicht schaden was
mindestens genauso schnell sein wird wie
unsere Seifenkiste ist eure
Steuererklärung und zwar mit steuerbot
dem Sponsor des heutigen Videos
steuerbot hilft euch im Schnitt 1095 € V
Start zurückzuholen weshalb ihr auch so
schnell sein müsst wie unsere
Seifenkiste weil die Frist um eure
Steuererklärung für letztes Jahr
einzureichen am 2.10 endet mit dem Chat
Layout von steuerwort seid da zum Glück
komplett papierlos unterwegs weshalb das
alles um einiges organisierter und
spaßiger abläuft als per Hand
irgendwelchen Papierkram auszufüllen und
ihr braucht im Schnitt nur 20 Minuten
bis ihr damit fertig seid und alles über
die App ans Finanzamt schicken
könnt es gibt also keinen Grund sich
nicht die im Durchschnitt 1095 € vom
stat zurückzuholen an Steuern die ihr
bereits gezahlt habt sogar vier Jahre
rückwirken geht das also wenn ihr noch
nie eine Steuererklärung gemacht habt
lohnt sich so richtig und genauso wie
wir später beim Seifenkistenrennen könnt
ihr dabei nur gewinnen weil bei einer
Rückerstattung von weniger als 50 € ist
steuerbard komplett kostenlos und bei
über 50 € zahlt ihr mit dem Code tommery
nur 2999 € die euch einfach von dem
erstatteten Betrag abgezogen werden den
Link Z steuerbard findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung also holt euch euer
Geld vom Start zurück und wenn ihr wollt
auch über diesen QRCode währendessen man
da drüben noch die Batteriehalterung
fertigweiß kümere ich mich mal um die
Elektronik in dem Fall können wir zum
Glück relativ viel von unserem alten
Projekt wieder verwenden von dem chetki
Video
[Musik]
was neu dazu kommt ist dieses Gaspedal
hier und dass ich halt noch den neuen
Motor verbinden muss mit dem alten
[Musik]
Motorcontroller
perfekt so jetzt noch das Gaspedal hier
ja perfekt der Controller kommt hier hin
das hier ist der Notaus ist die Frage wo
der hinkommt wscheinlich am besten
irgendwo hier vorne Kabelbinder hier
dran und das hält schon dann gucken ob
der Motor sich dreht R detection let's
[Musik]
go geil komplett SM wir wissen schon mal
dass der Motor auf jeden Fall
funktioniert und und jetzt gucken ob das
Gaspedal auch
funktioniert
[Musik]
Power ja funktioniert so und jetzt wo
die Elektronik auch läuft hoffen wir mal
dass die Jungs das Ding nicht abfackeln
damit ist meine Arbeit erledigt zurück Z
mano Lenkrad das da ursprünglich auf
diesem katc drauf war ist so ein richtig
windiges Plastik Teil als thas da drauf
gehockt ist hat er da dran rumgerissen
und irgendwie hatten wir alle Bedenken
dass er das Teil auf jeden Fall
abgerissen kriegt wenn er es probiert
deswegen haben wir dazu entschieden wir
holen uns ein richtiges Lenkrad dafür
brauchen wir jetzt nur noch die richtige
Aufnahme und ich würde sagen ich sitze
mir am PC zeichne das ganze in CD dann
kommt ein 3D Drucker und dann schauen
mal ob es
passt das passt richtig gut einfach der
Universalschlüssel Flex die Stange halt
noch werden wir nichts ändern können das
Lenkrad wird auf jeden Fall nicht
abfliegen so die Kette ist gerade
angekommen und damit ich weiß wo ich die
gleich kürzen muss lege ich die mal hier
an schaut auf jeden Fall schon mal aus
als wird's funktionieren was schon mal
ganz geil ist kann man hier dann noch
spannen hier muss ich jetzt die Kette
einmal
drennen ja so jetzt haben wir hier
unsere zwei Kettenenden von unserer
gekürzten Kette und die müssen jetzt
wieder zusammeng gemacht werden dafür
gibt's hier so einen verbindungslied das
wird jetzt hier einmal festgemacht dann
hier noch mal dann kommt hier oben die
stabile Platte drüber damit es auch was
aushält damit das jetzt nicht einfach
wieder rausfällt gibt es hier noch so
ein kleines Spann so eine kleine
spannbuchse oder Spannplatte und wird
jetzt hier drauf geschoben mit ein
bisschen Kraft ist gar nicht so einfach
wie es
aussieht ja und schon haben wir eine
vollständig geschlossene Kette die auch
was hält und in der perfekten Länge in
der wir sie
brauchen man sieht dass es noch ein
bisschen eiert aber ich glaube nicht
dass man da jetzt noch irgendwie groß
was machen kann die Welle ist halt ein
bisschen verbogen würde ich jetzt mal
sagen um zu gucken ob das Ding auch
wirklich das aushält was es später
machen soll nicht sehr schnell drehen
Meiß mal jetzt mal den Motor an und
beten am besten mal damit das Ding mir
nicht gleich um die Ohren fliegt
ja h das ja
[Musik]
beten
ja das da ist die Kette erstm wieder
runter damit sowas gleich nicht noch mal
passiert und die Kette wieder runter
springt muss ich jetzt diese zwei ritel
noch parallel zueinander ausrichten das
heißt ich tue jetzt hier unter dem Motor
noch ein paar Unterlegscheiben drunter
damit die wirklich perfekt auf einer
Ebene sind somit die Kette um einiges
flüssiger laufen
[Musik]
sollte
okay geil also der Notausschalter ist
mir besonders wichtigor das Teil jetzt
in die Luft fliegt ich habe ein bisschen
Angst das Problem ist aus stand fährt
halt
[Musik]
nicht das säuft ab wenn ich gut Gas geb
bisschen mehr
VIG
geil einfach der
Drift noch zu wenig Power ne wir machen
R Motor kleiner ja ja genau rel V
motorlein da kriegen wir noch mal 30%
mehr 40% ja dann bauen wir jetzt nocher
[Musik]
okay okay wir haben jetzt hier noch mal
ein anderes Zahnrad drauf anderes Ritzel
die Übersetzung jetzt anders und jetzt
sollte theoretisch mehr Power
haben ja hat er
wow er hat schon
Power also ja also man weiß auf jeden
Fall wieso echtes Auto eigentlich
Differential hat weil der hat überhaupt
kein Box zu Kurven zu fahren ne weil die
Reifen über eine Stange verbunden sind
und eigentlich in der Kurve die innere
langsamer sich drehen müsste als die
äußere man muss nur sehr vorsichtig
[Musik]
losfahren schon geil finde ich ziemlich
geil also man kann das Ding hier einfach
null ausfahren eigentlich also man darf
Hal auch nirgendswo fahren ne außer dann
irgendwie auf der Rennstrecke halt nach
einigen Modifikationen ja also die Räder
die funktionieren unabhängig von
vinander der blockiert jetzt nichts mehr
beim lenken wir haben Epoxidharz
reingegossen damit die Übertragung von
Achse zu Rad nicht wieder so durchbricht
wir haben hier vorne drauf jetzt die
Verkleidung das ist super wichtig und
nachdem Pascal jetzt in demem
geniestreichingekriegt hat dass der
Mutter jetzt auch aus dem Stand los
fährt in dem er noch so ein Sensor
eingebaut hat übrigens aktuell mit
dieser Batterie hier weil die Batterie
hier die hat zwar super viel Power und
auch super viel Kapazität aber die ist
die lebt nicht mehr die let nicht mehr
auf die hat noch irgendwie 80% drum heen
wir uns einfach fürs Rennen auf und
danach ist sie halt leer und hoffentlich
können wir die noch mal reparieren aber
zum Testen nutzen wir einfach die kleine
Batterie hier
und ich glaube man muss immer noch
leicht
anschieben aber nur noch leicht holy
Shit also wenn man ganz langsam fährt
bisschen Problem Motor aber wenn man
hier so dre K hat Schrittgeschwindigkeit
läuft super das beschleunigt richtig geh
viel mehr ab jetzt also es beschleunigt
richtig hart
[Musik]
jetzt der
bergauffahrtstest auch
easy in 30 Minuten müssen wir losfahren
in Richtung saand wo das Rennen
stattfinden wird wo ich die höllenkarre
an ihrer Grenzen bringen muss aber es
gibt noch ein Problem die Kette springt
immer ab also schweißt mano kurz vor
knapp noch eine Versteifung für unsere
Motorhalterung rein weil der Motor
einfach so viel Power hat dass wenn man
Gas gibt sich das Metallgestell verbiegt
und die Kette dann so locker ist dass
sie rausrutscht wir wollten das KZ dann
in den Tesla laden aber vollständig
zusammengebaut wurd das NX mit
abgeschraubten Sitz und Lenkrad hat dann
aber reingepasst Tag der Entscheidung
Thomas ist da ja hi tatsächlich ist es
so dass beide nicht wissen was der
andere gebaut hat ne wir haben wirklich
überhaupt keine ah also ihr habt auf
jeden Fall was anderes gewählt als wir
und ich wir haben auch sowas gesucht was
Größeres für erwachsen aber wir haben
nichts gefunden deswegen ist es
eigentlich für Kinder ja ich woll sagen
das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt die Größe
die man aber es halt also V allem ist es
halt für maximal 50 kg ausgelegt ja und
ich Wick halt so 75 ah okay verstehe ja
nee also von der Größe sind mir schon
mal
bisschen dann 3 2
1 ja also das ist schon deutlich okay
der Motor ist ist krass also der Motor
ist größer als unsere auf jeden Fall
also das ist unser Motor das ister Motor
putzig ist echt klein ja wir haben
einfach ketka gekauft wir haben ein paar
Sachen verstärkt also das denk das war
davor Plastik das ist jetzt halt es ist
WS immer no Plastik aber es hält
deutlich besser hier Gaspedal dran und
ja also dann halt der Motor ne der ist
halt klein wie viel Power hat er denn
der hat Spitzenleistung 8 kW
8000 Watt ja scheiße okay sagen unser
wir haben etwas weniger als 8000 das
kleine Ding hat 8000 Watt ja also 4 kW
wie gesagt normal aber Spitzenleistung 8
kW
ja aber du musst 4 kW rechnen nur ja
gerade gerade habe ich so eine kleine
Phase der Verzweiflung ja wias ist bei
euch ja keine
8000 geh rüber ja das Wichtigste ist wir
haben eine Klingel sicher ja ohne
Klingel läft gar nichts wir haben
vorwärtsrückwärtsgang wie du hier siehst
kann switchen also wir geil nicht
rückwärts ist aber sehr gefährlich
gemerkt haben und letzten Endes haben
wir einfach ein pedleeg Motor verbaut
allerdings in etwas stärkeren ach du
trhst und hast aber eine Unterstützung
dabei ja genau du musst also pedalieren
damit der Motor überhaupt erst anl und
dann haben wir hier unseren Turbomodus
noch und das ist ein 1800 wat Motor okay
aber dann s Hal auch bei insgesamt etwas
über 2000 ja und er könnt auch manuell
treten ja gut er muss aber auch Kraft
haben ne ich bin jetzt nicht der das
hast du jetzt gesagt du kannst mit
Fahrrad oder so kannst selber auch schon
20 kmh fahren ne richtig du kannst
treten bist du 25 kmh und jetzt kommt
wenn du hier drauf drückst quasi hast du
dann dein Turbomodus ja und das ist dann
wenn ein Fuß reinkommt ist das auch der
Fuß ist ab das ist in deinem Arm und
wenn Du runterfällst und nicht fallst
sondern wenn ich runterf dann fall ich
halt so aber geht das denn nicht du bist
do vom Gas weg wenn das Gas weg dann
bleibt e stehen oder nicht also
idealerweise schon ja wür man sich das
vorstellen ja kann der da noch brennen
eigentlich nee das haben wir
sichergestellt wir haben aktuell noch
ein Problem mit der Batterie uns fehlt
ein Adapter aktu noch gar kein Strom
wenn wir das jetzt behoben kriegen dann
glaube ich dass wir das gewinnen
werden so also es geht schon mal gut los
ja gut dass die Sicherheitsbeauftragte
gerade nicht da war ne so okay na ja
also jetzt isoliere ich das mal ab he
die sind ja richtig dick ich glaube wenn
ich den doppelt nehme kann ich
reinschieben ja das ist auf jeden Fall
eine solide
Verbindung ja ich glaube das hält schon
ganz gut ja cool ich bin gespannt ich
fin wie ich find's richtig geil was er
gemacht hab und ich habe echt überhaupt
keine Ahnung wie das also wir wissen
überhaupt nicht ne was jetzt passiert
weil wir überhaupt keine Ahnung haben
wie die Dinger irgendwie fahren also ich
glaub nicht dass es knapp wird ich
glaube dass einer den anderen auf jeden
Fall hart abziehen wird wir müssen noch
rausfinden wer auf die
Plätze fertig
[Musik]
los
boah war das krass das war ja unnormal
ja also am Anfang dachte ich noch ich
Chance habe ich gemerkt auf der gerade
bist du weg das hat richtig viel Spaß
gemacht ne ja ich habe verloren des
nicht muss überlegen okay wo kann ich
dich jetzt genau überholen ma ich das
aber ich kon immer noch nicht ausfahren
weil ja krass vielen dank vielen Dank an
Dich Alter war das Wild es war
unbeschreiblich krass ich bin noch nie
leben fahren übel geil das war so krass
also ich konnte noch nicht mal das Ding
ausfahren hey die Batterie geht wieder
die muss man nur mal gut durchpowern ich
hat ein bisschen Angst V meinem Leben ja
ich auch als ich dich gesehen habe wenn
ihr jetzt mal sehen wollt wie ich mit
diesem Gefährt hier von Christian fahre
dass sie zusammengebaut haben dann
schaut auf jeden Fall das Video von
denen an da habe ich das mal getestet
und mal ehrlich gesagt wie ich das so
finde jetzt im Vergleich vor allem zu
dem flitze der richtig gut abgeht mega
geile Nummer der Link Z steuerbard ist
auf jeden Fall eine Videobeschreibung um
im Schnitt 1095 € vom Start
zurückzukriegen das war's auf jeden mit
dem Video und ich bin damit raus macht's
gut